بعد هذه الضربة الأخيرة على هذه
القوات الأمريكية التي أصابت مرة أخرى عضوًا واحدًا على الأقل في
الخدمة الأمريكية. ما مدى قلقك
من احتمال التصعيد
قلق للغاية أه أليكس انظر
الوضع خطير للغاية إلى حد كبير
لأن الولايات المتحدة وإيران لديهما
أسوأ العلاقات بينهما  لقد
كان لديهم منذ عقود وأنت تعلم أن هذا
يقول شيئًا ما لأنهم لم يكن
لديهم أبدًا علاقات جيدة بشكل خاص ، لكن
دعني أذكرنا جميعًا بالقليل من
السياق التاريخي إذا عدت إلى الوراء
ست أو سبع سنوات فقط وقلت أنك تعرف
السنوات الأخيرة من  إدارة أوباما
حتى في العام الأول
لإدارة ترامب ، كانت إيران تساعد
الولايات المتحدة فعليًا على هزيمة داعش في العراق ،
كانت إيران ترسل ميليشياتها لفعل ذلك
كانت ملتزمة بصفقة أه النووية
التي كانت تلتزم بحدودها وكانت الولايات المتحدة
في حوار معها  بعد ذلك ، ينسحب ترامب
من الصفقة التي ترى إيران نفسها الآن في
صندوق يتعرض اقتصادها
للضغط عليها ، وهي يائسة وتبحث عن طرق
لإظهار أن لديها بعض
القدرة وأن هذه القدرة إلى حد كبير
لإثارة المشاكل التي تطلق العنان للمزيد
منها.  هذه الميليشيات التي ، كما
تعترف الحكومة الأمريكية ، ليس لديها
سيطرة كاملة عليها ولعبت دائمًا
لعبة سيئة مع ميليشيات مثل
حزب الله وتلك الموجودة في سوريا ، لذا
فإن الوضع برمته هو وضع
لا تملك إيران الكثير لتكسبه.  من أه من
استقرار الوضع يجب على
الولايات المتحدة أن تستجيب بشكل مبرر تمامًا
عندما تتعرض قواتها للتهديد
لكنك جمعت كل ذلك معًا وهو
برميل بارود